normalerweise bin ich immer ziemlich
motiviert zu beginn meiner videos
allerdings kann man bei diesem format
eigentlich nicht motiviert sein lokal
geht die besten damit herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren nach monaten mal wieder zu einer
neuen folge ich reagiere auf euch dem
sowohl simpelsten als auch beschützten
format auf youtube in diesem format geht
es darum dass ihr also die luchse
irgendwelche dummen videos auf twitter
instagram whatever mit dem hashtag luca
reagiert hochlädt und ich schaue mir
diese videos dann jetzt an wo ich bin
ganz aufgeregt
[Musik]
wow daran merkte direkt dass wir hier
beim qualitativ hochwertigsten youtuber
angekommen seid und ich scheiß auf alle
es diesen 600.000 euro rolls royce habe
ich in einem monat verdienen ja da würde
ich einfach nur sagen glückwunsch aber
summa summarum liegt aber im endeffekt
niemand wollte einfach witzig mal zu
europas führendem support immer gesagt
der kamin ischer punkt.de ja wahnsinn
ich erfreue mich wirklich die lupe eine
community zählen zu erwarten sei
cool süßes kaninchen das bin so ein
bisschen ich wenn ihr wie die hüften
sendet so ja gar keinen bock drauf
wow eine neue rolex ist das wirklich
eine neue rolex ist tot ja danke dafür
dass du mir deine katze als video
eingeschickt hast du grüne neune ist das
nicht der der freund diesen 600.000 euro
auto hat sich jetzt endlich auf zu
arbeiten wenn ich 600.000 euro hätte
würde ich auch nicht mehr arbeiten leute
was richtig geil ist ein skateboard
[Musik]
die luchse wirklich wahnsinn
dieses jahr findet ihr so was witzig ja
jannik jannik etwas davon scheiß was
hörst du da alle lieben mirko h
und wer er ist dass mirko ist halt alle
lieben heißt es packen halt da haben wir
das auch geklärt
eigentlich müsste das format von luca
reagiert umbenannt werden auf luca läuft
seine mutter einkaufen geht
sie fragt ob sie dir was mitbringen kann
und sie nein sagt auch danke für deine
einsendung
meine fresse herr gesangsverein habe ich
mich erst richtig
[Musik]
ok also er hatte er hat mir - eine
millionen abonnenten dahin gingst okay
wir sehen uns dann demnächst wieder bei
meinem 0 abonnenten special
also abonniert gerne einen kanal und
dann verlor sich eine mülltonne china
stiefel herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
oh mein gott das ist ja auch hatte da
irgendwie diese regional stiefel zu gast
das ist irgendwie eine der besten
mountainbike fahrerinnen und so wirklich
danke für euren geistreichen konnten den
er wirklich immer hier ein sender
die wird doch gar nicht berührt ich
hoffe sie hat das ganze überlebt du
heilige scheiße jetzt ist er wieder hier
aber gut was hast du uns denn diesmal
mitzuteilen
wir machen noch ein video ich wollte das
ziel anvisieren und bin seitdem nur noch
am trainieren
kein bock mehr wenn euch das heutige
wieder gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
das schaffen wir 50.000 likes auf jeden
fall krass und es wird mir zeigen
ihr habt bock dass sich öfter luca
reagiert hochladen schreibt mir das zu
dem geld und in die kommentare und das
hier war einer der top comments unter
der letzten folge und zwar welcher bus
hat angst vor pandas der bambus ja wenn
ihr mit eurem kommentar auch in die
nächste folge luca reagiert kommen wollt
dann kommentiert jetzt irgendwas hier
unter dem video abonniert main kanal
damit ich bald 0 abonnenten special
machen kann
wir wollten noch anderen das ganze müsse
[Musik]